the lgbt ideologues will claim  that men and women really are not  different at all and sex really is not  innate and not only can you change your  sexual desires you can change your sex  itself and we need to accept that too  within the same lgbt plus umbrella you  will find  bisexual and non-binary do you see the  problem with that  bisexual and non-binary cannot  simultaneously exist they make  completely opposite claims if if the  buys are right then the non-binaries are  not real if the non-binaries are right  then the buys are not real so why does  gender ideology not collapse under the  weight of its own obvious contradictions  because it isn't really an ideology even  the people who wave the ever-changing  rainbow flag ideologies express  a system of thought they are an  expression of the intellect what we call  gender ideology has no real intellectual  component